make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing out and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with world's funnest part to
Mixel pedelec and bat-mite versus the
specter and this is when things get
pretty crazy right because up to this
point I mean I guess it was about as
grounded as it could be right in terms
of seeing some wonkiness take place but
with basically the Legion of
super-heroes from the future being
destroyed the Justice League being
destroyed that managed Superman all
being destroyed there aren't really any
superheroes left in the world and so
this leads to essentially bat-mite kind
of disappearing and then mix up Italy
chasing him down and what that might
have done was basically go through and
change every single sign seemingly
across the world all the way only really
see it in one's in one one city two
Mixel petal ixnay spell backwards and
the reason why this matters is because
as most of you guys know when Mixel
pedelec says his name backwards he ends
up being sent back to the 5th dimension
and so it's just kind of like an
attempted ruse and that's literally what
it turns into you know it's basically
you know that might just trying to ruse
mix-up Italy and initially he almost
kind of Falls for it but he basically
realizes what's going on pretty fast and
where he's being surrounded by all these
things he basically just starts using
his powers to start warping all of
reality in the most extreme way it's
almost very mad Jim Jasper's you know in
terms of like the world being distorted
crooked all that kind of stuff and so
this leads to two one the revelation
that bat-mite and Mixel pedelec are
equal in terms of power and then to both
of them growing to enormous sizes and
then chasing each other around the world
right it really is just kind of like
them running in circles and so this
basically leads to like them continually
growing getting bigger and bigger
ultimately until the point where they're
basically as big as the world
Laoghaire there's one point where
they're fighting at the fortress of
solitude in the in the Arctic but
they're basically as big as Earth itself
and Mixel pedelec actually grabs the
earth to throw it at bat-mite and then
he suddenly stopped by the arrival of
the specter and the specter is kind of
like this has gone on long enough right
like this is kind of ridiculous you also
find his laid waste to the entirety of
the superhero community in the future
and in the present day you guys are
basically using the earth is just kind
of like a means to battle each other
like this is done right I representing
the power of the presence this is all
finished mixed up Italy grabs the earth
and cracks the specter over the head
with it knocks him out and the two of
them leave this is the power of Mixel
piddling now right just like this insane
level of reality manipulation now this
him and that might keep on fighting like
literally they're taking like stardust
and they're taking planets galaxies
like hitting each other with him to the
point that they actually start to
distort and then rip apart the entirety
of the universe to the point that they
end up completely and totally
obliterating it right so between this
fight the two of them have they destroy
the entirety of the universe right and
so from there like that might
immediately goes and runs into hiding
only to arrive in the Phantom Zone and
Mixel pedelec chases after and this
fight continues just like it did before
that mix-up hit like realizing he's in
the Phantom Zone basically ends up using
his power to destroy the entirety of the
Phantom Zone this leads to bat-mite
taking off yet again and then of course
bat-mite ends up arriving inside the
inside of earth to right into that earth
cue universe or he's met by the JSA the
Justice Society of America and it's kind
of cool the way this was written because
it gives us a little bit of like a tour
of basically earth - that we didn't
initially know that it was that this was
what it was or at least that might
didn't know what it was and of course
once you've got like dr. fate you've got
classic Superman you've got Hawkman Alan
Scott the Green Lantern kind of showing
up here other then it's like okay so
like well obviously we're in earth cube
and the funny thing is that because of
the fact that earth 2 was really
designed to be kind of reminiscent of
the 1940s that Mixel pedelec Sapir it
has totally changed right to where he
looks like a character that was drawn in
the 1940s and so of course the JSA is
kind of like okay guys we got to do our
duty we got to track down these two guys
and we have to defeat them the fight
ends like that I mean it ends the blink
of an eye the only one that has any real
fighting chance here is Johnny Thunder
and that's because of the fact that
Johnny Thunder basically possessed a
genie that allowed some measure of
reality warping but it's nowhere near on
the same scale as what Mixel peddling
and bat-mite can do and they end up
completely and totally killing the JSA
this leads to the intervention of the
specter yet again now the spectre as
they face him here is one of these funny
things because he's the JSA Specter and
when he kind of shows up immediately
just like all the other members of the
JSA one he's completely killed right
like literally he's turned into glass
and then shattered this leads to that
might taking off yet again and then
arriving in earth 3 right well
realistically have the crime syndicate
of America the evil version of the
Justice League these are the cool things
that we get here and this is why this
story world's funnest was exactly that
it was an amazingly fun story but he was
absolutely enjoyable right the jeaious
I'm sorry the the crime syndicate of
America are the the CSA basically we're
basically criminals right like it's the
you know for those you guys who don't
know earth 3 is a reality where
everything is inverted so all the people
who are norm
good guys or bad guys and all the people
who are normally bad guys are good guys
right so Superman's a bad guy instead of
it being Wonder Woman it's superwoman
right the flash is a bad guy you
basically got that power ring instead of
green lantern it's it's a cool concept
right and as one of these things were
like they don't initially know at least
the the crime syndicate doesn't
initially know everything that's going
on instead they're only here for a
moment right mix of pedelec and bat-mite
early here for a quick moment that might
basically bails out takes off and ends
up in the universe of Uncle Sam right
this is how all these things kind of
transpire they're just jumping from one
universe to the next from one reality to
the next they end up in the funny pages
right they actually end up an earth s4
time now if those guys who don't know
earth s it's kind of it gets a little
bit of a little bit murky here and when
DC sued Fawcett publications for
basically copyright infringement because
they had basically made a copy of
Superman as most of you guys know this
led to Fawcett basically going out of
business and then DC getting the rights
to - Shazam and so they basically kept
him on a back burner because he was so
similar to Superman and because of the
fact that he was a credible threat to
the Man of Steel in the sense that Billy
Batson is character he could fly before
Superman he had his own radio show
before Superman he was outselling
Superman DC didn't want to overshadow
their top start and so basically he was
sat on the back burner for 20 years now
eventually when Shazam did come back he
came back in his own universe right
didn't crossover with the main DC
Universe and it was called earth s or
earth Shazam where you had the whole
Shazam family and then you had like
other weird characters right like the
Shazam rabbit right Marvel bunny
basically different things like that and
that's what this is right it's just a
universe where everything's Shazam
related but bat-mite again takes off he
ends up in the world of the zoo crew and
the zoo crew all dude zoo crew man
captain carrot I love Captain carrot
captain carrot - superbunny he's amazing
I love captain carrot so much I don't
even know why right but like Earth see
like the universe composed of
anthropomorphic animals right it's all
basically the JSA but they're all
animals I wish DC would have done more
with this right because the zoo crew was
awesome I would love to read some
stories about the zoo crew right now
like and then these trying times I would
love to read a story just about about
the zoo crew right just anti-prom Orphic
animals who were basically superheroes
and Captain carrot I love the character
of Captain carrot but again you know
they don't last year very long they
basically teleport or at least bat-mite
teleports out of here he's chased down a
chase down by Mitchell pedelec and then
they end up in the real world and the
guy you actually see there holding the
that's Julius Schwartz right this guy
was instrumental for the introduction of
the Silver Age in the 1950s oh he's the
guy that came up with the idea of
blending superheroes with science
fiction themes him and like Edmund
Hamilton and a few other people here and
there Gardner Fox also was a had a huge
hand in all this but they're actually
terrified of the real world they're like
this place sucks and I can't blame them
and so they end up leaving end up
teleporting away but again that's how
this whole process goes over and over
and over again until it gets to the
point where they're kind of out in this
space and mix-up hit like you know where
you have a bat-mite trying to get mixed
with hit Alec to basically say his own
name backwards Mitchell pedelec finally
realizes hey I can I can cure this
problem so he ends up teleporting to the
fifth dimension which is basically like
a dr. Seuss looking place and like they
kind of make fun of him you know over
the idea that he's been sent back to the
fifth dimension by Superman who tricked
him and he's kind like no I came to the
realization that I don't really have to
go back to the fifth dimension
if the fifth dimension doesn't exist and
they're like but I mean if the fifth
dimension doesn't exist then like that
would mean that we're not here anymore
and Mitchell piddle looks like exactly
he annihilates the entirety of the fifth
dimension he destroys the whole thing
right it all gets wiped down and so
ultimately it's it's kind of nuts
because there's this moment where
bat-mite kind of tries to get mixed with
Hitler to say its first name and I don't
really know what the significance of
this is I've never seen this in DC
Comics before as far as I'm aware the
only importance of Mixel pedelec is if
he says his last name backwards ah which
I know kind of seems to be that maybe
he's trying to get him to say his own
his own last name backwards which bears
a question if that happens like does he
does not go anywhere is it just kind of
like he's free forever and never has to
go back to the fifth dimension if it
doesn't exist or like does he die does
he cease to exist right he's trying to
go back to a place that doesn't exist
and so he simply ceases to exist I have
no idea and we're not giving an answer
and the reason why is because we're done
with this video if you guys are no here
to comment explain make sure you guys
the sub button to become part of a dream
part of the rob for the guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like in the
next video we will have Mixel pedelec
and bat-mite versus dark side but that
being said guys I will see you all in
the next video peace
[Music]